Harry Houdini is widely regarded as one
of the greatest magicians escape artists
and showman of all time however he was
actually much more than this he can even
be considered a kind of polymath he was
a prolific writer he had a patent for a
diving suit he invented he was an
aviator and he was a Hollywood film star
for a time but perhaps what's most
interesting about Houdini is that many
of his tricks weren't in fact tricks at
all but rather simply examples of
incredible mastery over his own body he
may have had more in common with the
strongmen of his era such as the mighty
Adam or the inventor of muscle control
max ik either way he was a true legend
and in this video we're going to explore
a little bit about his life and also
what we can learn from his training and
how he can develop that same kind of
mastery
so Houdini was actually born Erik vice
in Budapest in 1874 he is one of seven
siblings and one of his brothers
actually also went on to become a
well-known escape artist he moved to the
US with his family in 1879 and there he
would change his name to Erik Vice the
German pronunciation although I may well
be saying that completely wrong as usual
in his youth air which was already
highly athletic he was a successful
runner a boxer and a gymnast at the age
of nine he became a trapeze artist known
as Erik Prince of air who would continue
practicing boxing gymnastics and
jiu-jitsu well into his adulthood Erik
also discovered his passion for magic in
his youth he was inspired by a fellow
magician who Dan whose name he borrowed
for his own act he falsely believed that
calling himself Houdini would translate
in French - like who Dan later on in his
life however he go on to become highly
critical of who Dan the name Harry might
well have come from Harry Keller who was
also a hero of his or it might have just
been an adaptation of Eric which becomes
arrey arrey Harry you get it as a
magician Harry got off to a somewhat
rough start to begin with his acts
focused mostly on card tricks and he
called himself the king of cards Yelp's
he already had a flair for the dramatic
it wasn't until he challenged a police
officer telling him that he could escape
from his handcuffs they would attract
the attention of the media that
obviously captured the public's
imagination and so for a while escaping
from handcuffs would become his bread
and butter he even called himself Harry
king of Han
cuffs it wasn't long however until he
started to develop his accent it became
much more dramatic and dangerous some of
his most famous acts included escaping
from milk cans water torture
straitjackets while suspended in midair
jail cells uniquely designed handcuffs
created especially to thwart him by
master locksmiths being buried alive
underwater coffins and even the stomach
of a beached whale or sea monster other
displays included to him materializing
through walls swallowing lots of needles
and then regurgitating them later on
threaded and even taking punches to the
stomach he'd also jump off of bridges
into rivers from great heights but the
real question that I'm interested in is
how how does Harry achieve all this and
what can we learn from Harry Houdini's
training well it's only right to point
out that some of Harry's tricks were
indeed just that tricks or illusions
they might incorporate trapdoors for
instance he was also a keen businessman
and not above occasionally
anti-competitive measures however we
shouldn't overlook that many of his acts
were also fully real and examples of
incredible dexterity strength and
bravery it's well known for instance I
collected hundreds upon hundreds of
locks and shackles and chains would
practice unlocking them breaking out of
them sometimes he'd quickly open them
using concealed picks other times he'd
apply force in the correct manner to
break them open his knowledge of locks
was second to none at one point he was
even considering becoming a locksmith
himself and is even enlisted by the US
Army to help train the troops so they
could escape capture as well Houdini
practice with single-minded
determination the same kind of absolute
dedication and passion that we've seen
with several other people I've talked
about on this channel like Bruce Lee or
da Vinci he was constantly practicing
like wim HOF many years later
Houdini's training also involved
submerging himself into ice-cold water
in a bathtub that he kept in his home
this would shock his nervous system and
he then practiced bringing it back under
conscious control he'd also practice
holding his breath in here and reports
vary on precisely how long he could hold
his breath for but the best estimate
seems to be three minutes forty seconds
of course right now that's nothing
spectacular some free divers can hold
their breath for 10 15 even 20 minutes
David Blaine managed to hold his breath
for an impressive
ten minutes on the stage but at the time
it was extremely impressive and it
wasn't his only feat of breath control
another act he was sealed inside an
airtight coffin underwater for 90
minutes and used very shallow breaths in
order to keep himself calm and not use
up all the oxygen he's talked in the
past about the importance of keeping
calm and focused even in
life-threatening situations and it's
highly likely that he had some kind of
meditation or practice breathing as part
of his training this is all something
that we'll be diving into in more depth
and future no pun intended in short it
seems that Houdini had the uncanny
ability to control aspects of his
autonomic nervous system consciously is
something only a few other individuals
have demonstrated the ability to do
since Houdini was generally fascinated
with the human body and uncovering his
notes we see lots of sketches of anatomy
and musculature in one sketch from his
notes we see the spine split into the
five sections demonstrating mobility and
flexibility another aspect of Houdini's
training was training his internal
organs in order to be able to perform
that regurgitation trick he would
practice swallowing objects tied to
string then going about his business as
normal
before regurgitating them whole much
later on again this seems to show that
with practice you can gain great control
even over the muscles in your stomach
it's maybe possible due to motor neuron
plasticity the branching of nerves and
the creation of new asset I'll :
receptors he also developed his
dexterity to an incredible degree he was
likely ambidextrous purely through
practice and he could control his feet
with great dexterity to reportedly his
training involved tying and untying
knots repeatedly with his toes and it's
been said that he achieved the same kind
of dexterity in his toes that the
average person would have in their
fingers control of the feet hands even
organs an autonomic response can
potentially be seen as extensions of
muscle control this is a concept that
was big during Houdini's heyday and that
was employed by many strongmen in order
to accomplish their amazing
demonstrations of raw power if he
followed the bio near then you'll know
what muscle control is it basically
means the ability to recruit more motor
units not only within the muscle that
you can already consciously control but
also within smaller and more obscure
muscles someone with great muscle
control might be able to flex a lat or
trap without contracting the surrounding
muscle and reports seem to support that
Houdini was into this kind of thing they
recount his ability to make muscles pop
up and contract
in his hand in his forearms even his
little finger and it's been suggested
that Houdini actually learned the
ability to contract his stomach and take
punches from the mighty Adam this would
come in handy when his escape and cuffs
or needs escaping straitjackets the way
he would escape from straitjackets was
by expanding his chest and arms whilst
the straitjacket was applied that way he
then have slack in order to escape
subsequently in his book muscle control
max ik who was another contemporary
strongman explains how you can develop
more of this mind muscle connection with
the muscles in your body you can
practice this yourself try putting a
hand on your lap and just gradually
trying to flex it and feel it move
without moving the rest of your body
likewise you can make your forearms
contract imagine that you're trying to
squeeze a ball but at the same time not
move your hand and you can see the
muscles in your forearm moving to get it
you'll be able to command those muscles
at will and will be more conscious of
them during movements Houdini
demonstrating an entirely different use
for this same concept exploring hitherto
unknown capabilities of the human body
many believed that it was taking a punch
to the stomach before being properly
prepared that ultimately killed Houdini
in fact though it's more likely that
this simply masks for the severity of an
unrelated issue with his appendix
Houdini died in 1926 on Halloween at the
age of 52 leaving behind an incredible
legacy inspiring countless future
performers and becoming a true cultural
icon so I found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like please share it around
comment down below let me know what you
think of Houdini
were there any awesome feats or facts
about him that I missed that you'd like
to share likewise let me know who else
you'd like me to cover in future in this
Legend series I've got lots more on the
way of course I'll be talking about
programming cyber security as well as
balanced training and vo2 max I've got
the Nightwing part three that is on the
way so if that all sounds good then
thanks a ton for watching and I'll see
you next time
bye for now